all right let's let's start with some
video here uh we've got this elderly man
who's pretending to be president of the
united states joe biden listen to this
let's be clear
vaccination requirements should not be
another issue that divides us
that's why we continue to battle the
misinformation that's out there
and companies and communities are
setting up their uh stepping up as well
to
combat these
the misinformation
southwest airlines at the head of the
pilot the head of the pilots union and
the ceo dismissed critics who claim
vaccination mandates contributed to
flight disruptions
school board members
religious leaders and doctors across the
country are fighting misinformation and
educating people about the importance of
vaccines
all these efforts are going to help us
continue moving the dial
to eliminate this disease
all right i like to i like to give
credit where credit is due uh he read
off the teleprompter pretty well there
jesse he doesn't want us to be divided
if we just do what he says we won't be
divided right come on
i don't know why you're dividing us dave
if you would just do what your lord and
master says we won't be divided do i
have to hit you again i just look it's i
don't want to hit you again but i'll hit
you again if you don't do what i say why
are you for my own good
that this is this is beyond the
creepiness of the fact we have a half
functional president i realize we all
make fun of that now but have you
actually thought about that that's the
commander in chief the leader of the
free world he is not a fully functional
adult and now it's happened so long
which just kind of baked in the cake
it's like oh that's old joe that's the
president that's the president of the
united states of america that's one too
isn't this whole thing beyond creepy how
you're not allowed to discuss anything
except the vaccine no natural immunity
remember when they they started banning
hydroxychloroquine you're not allowed to
talk about ivermectin you're not allowed
to talk about sunshine you're not
allowed to talk about not being fat
anymore you're not allowed to talk about
anything only the vaccine anything else
is shouted down it doesn't take a
right-winger to think that's really
really creepy and something's off
how about herd immunity remember that
phrase we don't talk about herd immunity
anymore
now they just update all the definitions
of things to fit the current climate so
that when you talk about hurt immunity
now you're an insane person because
apparently that's not a thing anymore
but sydney but sydney he said it right
there i mean he's basically saying you
know people like us we're spreading
misinformation you've got your on-air
partner elijah over there reading
statements i mean misinformation what
are you guys doing
it's i mean i think what my frustration
is is that even if you don't have the
greatest grasp of biology or how a lot
of this stuff works i freely admit i'm
not an expert when it comes to any of
this but i go it's really strange to me
that we can't even have a conversation
about it that we're really at a point
where they go no no no discussion can go
down whatsoever because if you are
talking about it and it's contrary again
to the narrative then there's something
wrong with that excuse me and you must
stop you must stop and it must never
happen like what really this thing that
we've had uh since the beginning of time
in humans which is natural immunity why
is that banned on instagram why can't
you search that term on instagram or
even just why is it the one elijah says
that there's no efficacy of masks in
children why is it that that gets wiped
off the internet this whole thing
especially with biden and it's like
jesse says you know we laugh about it
because it's humiliating but on a world
stage it's so humiliating that this is
the leader of the free world and you
have to say well because what does that
even mean anymore it is and i i don't
mean to interrupt but i just have to
point this out too just piggybacking off
what sydney just said the social
distancing thing
we've moved so far past that we don't
even laugh about that anymore appointed
i am or can we just bring up how
ridiculous it is that the leader of the
free world and the most technological
technologically advanced country in the
world and the richest country in the
world got a virus and the solution was
stand six feet away from each other and
not only was that the solution to this
day you see it now you're still standing
in footsteps in grocery stores across
the country that's something a toddler
would come up with just stand away from
him daddy then you'll be safe and yet
this is something the the most powerful
country in the world did as a matter of
policy it's insane right exactly you you
go to every you go to every airport and
they're jam-packed right now because of
flight cancellations we'll get to that
in a second and yet they've got signs
everywhere saying social distancing
which nobody's doing but elijah to that
point he even in that very statement
that he read he shared misinformation
when he started talking about southwest
which canceled thousands of flights this
week because we know that they were
protesting the vaccine mandates the the
ceo he also sort of lied about what the
ceo said because the ceo kind of said
that's what happened um but is it
possible that flights can only be
affected by weather if they're southwest
flights and not other flights because
that's basically that's basically what
joe's saying
yeah you know i think what it is is
we've come into a place where truth
matters so little that people pretty
much say whatever they want and i've
heard it said that the media and the
government have sort of become like a
father who has been out of a child's
life for 10 years and suddenly pops back
in and tries to pretend like they know
them and we're the child and it's like
dad we are so we're decade apart we are
way beyond you we have grown up we have
grown past you we don't need you and
don't try to come back in my life
because you just quite frankly weren't
needed and i figured out how to how to
go about and so you're going to
complicate things and when they say you
know the southwest airlines were about
uh you know i don't know pilots being
upset as upset about what because when i
see gadsden flags hanging out of out of
southwest plains i'm like come tread on
me daddy you know i'm going who's daddy
and who's treading what is this is this
about a two dollar you know wage uh
increase of course not we're in the
instrumental part of our society
where we are segregating people i mean
we are already seeing the introduction
of blood-based
passports internationally from the world
economic forum i mean they are talking
about bringing gattaca and these movies
to life putting taking our blood samples
using that as a direct input to give us
clarity to travel and to buy things
around the world and it's not just a
future idea i mean the largest banks in
in australia even the the grocery stores
um like woolworths and coals not to be
confused the american coals with the k
this is where the c are are you know
going to be linking you know the same qr
code system for payment that they are
for the vax passport but yet are saying
they won't be linked together in
whatever way that that means i mean we
are headed towards an absolute
tyrannical communist regime and people
at least before they're going to get
violent which they will
are at least protesting the only way
they know how and then they're being uh
dismissed by a half-present president
i could say this will spell nothing but
disaster and it's also humiliating like
jesse says it's humiliating that we've
come to accept this i haven't i'm still
laughing at these people and now i'm
getting pissed and i kind of want to see
more happen